robert's Mugabe's burial was subdued
very different from the large crowds he
used to attract during his political
rallies that's because his family wanted
to give him a private send-off with
close friends and some people from his
village in Zumba were invited to come
and say goodbye for weeks there was a
dispute between the government and
Muhammad's family over where he should
be buried in Zimbabwe people are usually
buried within a week Mugabe died at a
hospital
in Singapore more than three weeks ago
Roberts miyabi's family say he was angry
the army removed him from power two
years ago it's widely believed to be one
of the reasons why there was a dispute
over the burial place government
officials later related saying they'll
respect the family's wishes president
I'm assumin and Galois had first pushed
for macabre to be buried here at the
national heroes echo cemetery in the
capital Harari
a special mausoleum was being built for
him but in the end Mugabe's family had
the final say and he once said I think
history to still revolve around
undermining the man of his removal from
power and the only way of demonstrating
that would be to say I'm not going to be
I'm not happy with the manner in which
am removed from office during his early
years as President Mugabe was praised
for improving access to health and
education for the poor but nearly four
decades later millions of the bodwins
are struggling with soaring inflation
and high unemployment he got his final
wish to be buried in his home village
but he leaves behind a ruined economy
and a divided political environment
Carew Mutasa
aljazeera Zumba Zimbabwe